Yannick mauvaise a démissionner et il ne
reviendra pas sur sa décision le maire
de Saint-Brevin-les-Pins est ainsi
devenu depuis quelques jours le symbole
des difficultés des élus locaux à
exercer leur mandat non plus seulement
apporter d'engueulade mais bien de
calomnies d'agression aussi et dans ce
cas d'un attentat criminel qui aurait pu
le tuer sa femme et lui il y a une
mauvaise n'a pas démissionné par peur ou
par lassitude il a démissionné parce que
l'État ne l'a pas protégé Yanni moresse
depuis l'incendie de sa maison le 22
mars était devenu le symbole du courage
de l'élu républicain celui qui assume
sans faiblir la tâche que lui a confié
l'État en l'occurrence le déménagement
d'un centre d'accueil pour demandeur
d'asile un cada déjà installé sans
problème dans la commune depuis 2016 il
est en tribune et c'est d'abord à ce
titre que nous lui rendons hommage il
tenait bon face à la haine de l'extrême
droite et des sbires Éric Zemmour
monsieur le ministre qu'il n'y ait pas
de faux débat nous condamnons tous ici
toutes les violences politiques et je
voudrais associer à l'expression de
notre dégoût face à ce cas subi Yannick
Morel c'est ignoble passage à tabac
avant-hier du neveu de Madame Brigitte
Macron c'est aussi un acte qualifiable
et la justice doit être ferme dans un
cas comme dans l'autre mais je vous
demande
mais je vous demande précisément
monsieur le ministre de répondre aux
interrogations de Yannick Morel nous lui
devons s'écarter première question
pourquoi Yannick Morel n'a-t-il pas fait
l'objet d'une protection rapprochée de
l'État depuis le mois de mars deuxième
question pourquoi avoir autorisé la
manifestation anticada du 29 avril un
mois après l'incendie véritable désaveu
du maire qui avait pourtant demandé son
interdiction le 14 mai le 14 avril
après Kalak après Saint-Brevin et avant
d'autres drames allez-vous enfin
interdire ce type de manifestation qui
sont d'évidence appel à la haine de la
part de l'extrême droite
[Applaudissements]
pour vos réponses la parole est au
ministre de la cohésion des territoires
monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur dentaire
d'abord vous me permettrez en saluant
Yannick Morest de me réjouir de l'image
que vient de donner le Sénat puisque
aucun membre n'est resté assis au moment
de l'hommage qui lui a été rendu alors
que nous avons assisté hier
alors que nous avons assisté hier à
l'Assemblée nationale à une scène où une
partie de l'hémicycle ne s'est pas levée
et je pense que sa témoigne précisément
de la volonté qu'il y a
de la
j'aimerais
prétendre défendre la liberté
d'expression en empêchant quelqu'un de
s'exprimer et toujours quelque chose qui
m'a semblé bizarre je commence ce propos
en saluant le fait que tous les élus sur
tous les bancs ici se lèvent alors
qu'hier le rassemblement national a
refusé de se joindre à l'hommage et vous
prétextez que compte tenu de la
formulation de ma phrase ça engendrerait
la moindre gêne
c'est un début de récupération que de
laisser penser qu'il y aurait une façon
qui serait à géométrie variable de
décrire les choses et je veux saluer les
propos de ronanantec qui sent la moindre
hésitation et avec le sens républicain
conduit connaît on a profité aussi pour
rappeler les faits inacceptables subis
par le petit neveu du président de la
République dans un continent de violence
qui de cette manière là se retrouve
mesdames et messieurs vous avez ce matin
reçu Yannick Mores dans le cadre d'une
mission plus large portée par le
sénateur d'Arnaud par l'avenir de la
commune nous allons avoir trois quatre
cinq questions qui seront autant
d'occasions de vous répondre dans les
minutes qui viennent
et je me réjouis que le Sénat au travers
de cette exemple d'un acte de courage
d'intimidation et d'un niveau de
violence qui a été franchi et qui a
atteint des paliers inacceptables essaye
de faire la lumière ce que je souhaite
dans le même temps y compris contenu des
retours que nous avons c'est que vous en
profitiez peut-être pour demander aux
forces de l'ordre à ceux qui travaillent
au sein de Loire-Atlantique qu'elle a
été leur version de leur côté les
retours qu'ils ont eu dans les éléments
qui nous sont donnés il y a eu des
patrouilles de police plusieurs nuits
dans la foulée immédiate du 22 mars je
vous dis ce que je sais il y a eu des
propositions qui ont été faites auprès
d'Yannick Maurice pour faire en sorte
qu'il puisse bénéficier d'un
accompagnement et des tentatives de
prise de contact de la part de la
préfecture ou de la sous-préfecture
j'entends y compris dans la lecture de
ce qui a été l'audition ce matin qui a
manifestement sur l'absence de réunion
publique sur des manifestations qui se
sont tenues des zones d'ombre qui
convient d'éclaircir ce que je pense
c'est qu'une commission aussi importante
que celle là sur un sujet aussi sensible
nécessite sans doute que vous y passiez
encore un peu plus de temps que ce que
vous aviez pu imaginer
[Applaudissements]
quelques secondes monsieur Dantec il
vous reste quelques secondes si vous le
souhaitez oui juste monsieur le ministre
je crois qu'il n'y aurait pas de honte à
reconnaître que sur cette affaire l'État
n'a pas été à l'auteur ça faciliterait
les choses
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]